foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Escape
um yeah
um
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
okay
[Music]
welcome John thanks elkinson it's uh I'm
really looking forward to having this
conversation too with you it's a
pleasure meeting you an honor
um how is it to visit Denmark on such a
beautiful spring night I don't want to
go back
simple answer yeah it when I look into
your book it's green spawns that we're
going to talk about and also other
interviews you've done it seems like you
had a bit of a love affair with this
country is that true
I first came to Denmark in 1969
um the woman the young woman who became
my wife had a Swedish boyfriend before
so we hitchhiked up to Stockholm to see
him and then we hitchhike back
and we slept in a bus shelter on the
outskirts of Copenhagen that first time
but there was a wonderful man who picked
us up from he was going to a steel mill
and he was going to sign a big contract
that day and we just we he got us into
his car
and we were driving where he's going to
drop us off and he suddenly said
he said no during the war
your country played an important role
I'm going to take you to the coast now
I'm going to take you to the harbor but
can I stop off and make a telephone call
and tell the steel mill I'm going to
come later I just thought that was just
what an introduction
to a country and then later in the
late 1980s I started coming particularly
to work with Nova Nordisk but that's
another story and yeah but I can read in
the book that you praise Novo Nordisk on
being one of the first big companies
large companies to really turn itself
around the the triple bottom line
um I can also read that you look who
worked together with Copenhagen business
school I don't know if there's some
students from there tonight uh yeah
there is
um but most importantly
Wikipedia at some point made up that you
had a Danish wife you didn't even know
nothing about it it may have been real a
reality I don't know but I didn't know
about her until that point yeah I very
rarely looked at Wikipedia and and the
one side
the first time I ever did I saw that
fact well nice surprise yeah uh but I'm
so proud yeah you you refer to and
erson and you do that because uh you
also describe the pre-stage of the
Greenspoint or the black or the gray or
the blue
the ugly ducklings
um I would like to start out with asking
you why do did you feel the urge to
change the Black Swan
into a green Swan phenomena
well I I love books I mean I think you
do too and what a wonderful place to be
talking about books and every so often
one comes along that just has a
transformative effect
on the way that
any one of us thinks about the world and
and when Nasim Nicholas Talib wrote The
Black Swan and that was published in
2007 just ahead of the financial crash
and every thought everyone thought he
was a prophet and and and as you know
what he was saying that every so often
out of the blue comes something that is
completely unexpected
uh and I I love that book I love the
idea of the Black Swan
but I wondered whether there would be a
special class of black swans because he
also he covered problems and challenges
and he also covered Solutions but
whether there was a special class that
would be
exponential solutions to things like
climate change
um but also to some of the other uh
challenges that the sustainable
development goals uh flag up so I also
like playing with metaphors and it was
just it seemed to be a nice one at the
time
could you just um take out the most
important characteristic for a green
swan
well for me it is in part that they are
an exponential trajectory and I since
the book came out from different parts
of the world people have been sending me
copies of photographs or actually
examples of their business cards in
which they say no no I work in the
Philippines or Indonesia and I'm a green
Swan that really wasn't the idea the
idea I mean I like it I mean it's
wonderful and I know more power to them
but
the idea was that these were
technological Market
political cultural Trends with the
potential after a period of growing
relatively slowly to suddenly go through
an inflection point and take us
somewhere quite unexpected and the
problem is things like covid-19 take us
places we really don't want to go at an
expansion rate
so the character the key characteristic
is that these things at least have the
potential
to go viral in a good way to sort of
scale and replicate to use the sort of
Silicon Valley language you've mentioned
the internet the cell phone technology
but also the vaccine technology we're
actually which some of it actually came
out of covet
well it it it's interesting because
um you if somebody had said in the 1950s
or 60s we would all be walking around in
our pockets
with what we now call a cell phone but
would then have been a super super
computer linked to this thing the
internet I mean there were a few science
fiction authors talking about that uh
sort of future
but it just was beyond our imagination
and the idea of the green Swan is that
already in our world there are people
working on solutions to some of the
absolutely critical existential
challenges that we face is a species and
at least some of those with the right
following wind and support and the rest
of it could take us again to good places
that we didn't expect to be so it's
fundamentally an optimistic and and I
hope hopeful
um a line of argument
so you wrote green swans what was what
was the urge why did you want to read
exactly that book because you you you
wrote about 20 books
um so what what was the why was there a
need for especially in this book
well let me start personally and then
I'll I'll talk about the need because I
when I was a child I watched a chicken
being cut open and I've been a
vegetarian for 45 years did you wish I
watched I watched the chicken and and
you may all know but but a chicken is
it's true with um girls and women too
that all of the eggs that they will ever
lay is in their their body already when
they're they're very very young indeed
and I feel the same with books I I feel
that um if anyone had told me when I was
a child I would write even one book I
just thought absolutely screaming
nonsense it cannot happen I didn't come
from a family where that was done
um but I have that sort of compulsion to
write
um and I often say that if I want to
learn about something I write a book
because it's it's a good excuse to go
and you do a reflection right yeah and
and I hadn't written a book for a few
years and and that one started to
bubble up because I'd I'd been to places
like Silicon Valley and other places Los
Angeles and so on to talk to some of the
people working on exponential technology
and although some of them are absolute
in Nut Cases some of them are you know
even some of the nutcase tell us tell us
some examples of that well I I once
worked uh in the world economic Forum
with Larry Page of Google and
it's a different species really uh but
you know they do things which
periodically they move humankind better
as well they do Elon Musk another
example yeah and and um so the idea
started to form and the idea of the ugly
duckling came as part of that because I
thought most green Swan trajectories and
so on on
they're not born full-fledged I mean
they they evolve over time and very
often to start with
they look really peculiar I mean they
really do and and um so how do you see
the potential
well when I was saying you know things
look peculiar I just I was remembering
last night being in the boardroom at
Ford in Dearborn outside
um Michigan and the early part of this
century
and talking to people like Bill Ford and
others about
uh Elon Musk because it was a 2003-2004
he was just setting up Tesla and I said
you know that that's really interesting
and the answer I got was oh we tried
electric vehicles a hundred years ago it
didn't work uh and and it's not going to
work again and I'm not claiming to be
any sort of prophet or whatever but
every so often you see something
that looks so seriously strange that
it's worth paying attention to and
I just I like to be on the edges of any
system I like to talk to the people who
aren't currently on the mainstream so it
used to be environmental activists it
used to be human rights people it then
went to social entrepreneurs social
innovators then exponential thinkers now
it's people working on regenerative
farming and so on and part of the the
story is to try and understand what
they're doing
understand what
they're doing that might actually become
more mainstream over time and then just
giving that a little bit more of a okay
so look look outside the mainstream yeah
that's a good idea we we talk about this
technology and not because of the
technology but because it should help us
saw the climate change and the climate
chaos
um we just had another Dreadful U.N
report coming out
um about a month ago
um and once again we know that from
science that the clock is really ticking
yeah and we don't know if if we can
actually reach the 1.5 degree and it
seems harder and harder are we getting
past the Tipping Point or what are the
yeah actually what what are the
possibilities that we can actually
reverse this
um
we know all the facts we have all the
signs yeah
and we work on technology but still it
seems like we don't work hard enough why
is it so difficult for us to act
I wish I had a simple answer to the
question but
um I think it's a species we when faced
with something that is right in front of
us a bull or a motorbike or whatever it
is coming at us very fast and very hard
we'll act our reflexes
um
trip in and we become active or we're
dead so it's a natural selection
pressure but with these very big
systemic crises
it's much harder firstly to see them
because very often it's scientists who
see them first and then the question is
do we trust
the science and very often what you find
is is public relations agencies like
Burson marstellar and so on start to
sort of throw up dust clouds to sort of
mask what's going on because they pay to
do that by the tobacco industry or the
lead in gasoline industrial now the
fossil fuels sectors
so I I think there are people who
actively trying to ensure that we don't
see what's going on but I also think
it's a species we're a herd animal
and we tend to leave things routinely
too late and then we Stampede we know
it's very difficult to change habits it
is and and and and the one what I've
just said I mean will sound very
pessimistic I also think to that Tipping
Point I read this um reports and I I go
and visit some of the scientists who
work on these sorts of issues about 20
years ago in fact exactly 20 years ago I
went to the woodso oceanographic
institution on Cape Cod and the director
took my wife and I around for just a
full day
and we met all of the leading climate
scientists and I thought I knew about
climate science then
and I came out literally we would say
with my knees knocking because the scale
of what they were already seeing then 20
years ago with the the deep currents
starting to shift
it was terrifying and they were saying
you know if this continues within about
40 to 50 years we're going to be in
Western Europe back to West Siberia was
and and so the question you've just
asked me about I I constantly ask myself
why is it
that even if the science is there
we cannot take it on board that
because is it psychological is it
emotional is it is just a belief that
nothing like that can possibly happen
um but but just to go optimistic in a
way
I think that
as a species we tend to leave things way
too late but then we act in very short
order we start to do things and it's
often too late and and now I think in
some senses it's it's certainly too late
to stay under 1.5 degrees I mean as the
UN says you know we'll be there in just
a few years the question is whether
that's a a terrible thing and I think it
will be but whether it has good aspects
whether it will so terrify people that
you'll then finally start to get people
acting but I think we'll still see those
problem Industries lobbying extremely
hard either publicly or very often
behind the scenes and somehow we've got
to address that problem
um the German Vice counselor Robert
habik was on this stage
um about a month ago and he said that we
do not need change to protect the
climate we need change to protect
Humanity yeah
do you agree on that
one of the people who had I think a huge
influence on my thinking I first came
across in
1975 I I gave up science when I was 14.
I refused to cut up frogs so I was told
I couldn't do biology and if I couldn't
do biology I couldn't do chemistry and I
couldn't do physics bless you but I then
had one of these moments where
um
it was it was a benefit because I came
into science writing and and and
not being a scientist helped
but the one of the magazines I started
to write for new scientists published in
1975.
an article by somebody called James
Lovelock about the Gaia hypothesis it
was one of those moments where you just
saw
an argument an explanation for where we
are as a species which is I spoke to me
incredibly powerful and later on I got
to know him before he died
and um to your question I think
I think science is has is changing
changing quite fundamentally and people
are beginning to see the systemic
aspects of our interrelationship with
um the planet and to the point that this
is about saving Humanity not about
saving the climate that's what Lovelock
said for about 40 years
um so I I I think it's correct but it is
also about saving the climate because as
the climate changes
every other species on Earth pretty much
is going to be advantaged or
disadvantaged so the repercussions of
biodiversity are going to be huge so
even though you have looked into the
science you've looked into the facts for
so many years you're still optimistic
why is that because I was born that way
I mean in the sense that you you can't
do I mean there are people in the
audience who will come from activist
groups Greenpeace and people like that
and how have people like that continue
to hammer away over so many decades and
sometimes it's the organization not not
the individuals but
I'm optimistic in the sense that I
believe in progress
and I also believe that we're not
entirely stupid as a species I think
that but is it is it too late that's the
big question all the time you know is it
too late to be optimistic for many
things it is too late
um and and if you look back at the
history of our species we have a
criminal record of crashing ecosystems
and then moving on it's it's sort of
what we do we've got this last chance to
sort of try and overcome in a sense that
criminal record I still believe we can I
still believe that some Trends are
moving very much in our favor but you
must be optimistic also because you've
seen examples on how business work with
this how they actually develop new
technologies that can help us and so on
yeah where do you see the coming green
swans where should we look for them
one of the groups that I've I've really
admired for a very long time is called
rethink X and they're based in Silicon
Valley and in the UK
and some people in the audience will
have heard of them and if you haven't I
really do recommend their work and the
first study that they did was on
transportation and Mobility
and they talked about a future into the
2030s
where there's a huge transformation in
the automobile industry in particular
with electrification and so on
but one of the arguments they made is
you're going to see a 50 increase in the
kilometers traveled by Humanity over the
next sort of few decades but you're
going to see something like a 60
collapse in the revenues going to the
oil companies going to the automotive
companies and so on so they're looking
structurally at what's going to happen
so you're absolutely right in the sense
that they're in our Trend and they
looked at cattle ranching and daring
they've looked at Renew energy and
they've looked at finance and so on and
then every one of these sectors you see
these Trends building
the issue is that the social shock waves
that will come from these disruptive
changes in our economies need hugely
intelligent long-term political planning
to make sure that people are re-skilled
and moved between sectors and so on and
largely we're not doing that yet and
we're particularly not doing it in
countries like the United States so the
the social shock waves almost the future
Shockers have Alvin Toffler would call
it well I've called it it's going to be
profound
yes because a lot of of the the examples
we've talked about when green swans how
to change the climate is around
technology yes but you're also saying
maybe we can find chain change elsewhere
could we could we look for
a huge change in how we deal with the
climate change in other sectors than
technology well I think firstly we
forced ourselves into a corner now where
we have no option but to do carbon
capture and we have no option but to do
things that are called geoengineering we
start to put
compounds into the oceans to sort of
pull carbon out of the atmosphere and so
on
but I actually think that there will be
a cultural response to this at some
point people particularly
younger people as you know are
increasingly talking about degrowth and
how do we just step off the treadmill of
just constantly growing our GNP and so
on I think it's a it it's a very
intriguing idea I think it's a very
dangerous one too because if you've
stopped our economy is dead now the
again the social repercussions of that
would be profound so a lot of this
depends on really intelligent
politicians and you've had fun on the
stage just very recently but most
politicians with the greatest respect
even if they start that way they don't
end up that way because the game that
they're forced to play is just a
different one yeah we'll talk more about
the political systems I promise
I'm just trying to to spot if there
could be a new generations of solutions
out there in areas where we haven't
really looked the past decades well I
think you know you look at the
Industrial Revolution
why did that happen well one of the
reasons was that my own country ran out
of Timber
because we've been cutting down all the
trees to build ships to sort of take
over the world
um and and we ran out of fuel that way
so we discovered Co and and all of that
happened and now we're in a very similar
situation where all sorts of things are
becoming are going to become scarce so
you know this is mad scramble this Gold
Rush for lithium and and all sorts of
rare earth metals and so on
that will drive Innovation and sort of
batteries in the future will be built
out of material so we can scarcely even
begin to imagine today so in is that
going to happen in the next five to
seven years I don't think so is it going
to happen in your lifetime it's almost
guaranteed the question is does that
happen fast enough is it deployed in an
inclusive way where people aren't
disadvantaged unnecessarily by that and
does it happen around the world does it
just happen the global North or parts of
the global North how do we actually make
sure that it happens right around the
world it seems sometimes that we're
looking for miracles but you know
um yeah in a very
um in a way that we we want to we really
want to get this done if we have to
survive I know there's quite a lot of
Business Leaders in the audience as well
and I know you advise many Business
Leaders and boards
what is what is your advice to them at
the moment on how they should look for
these miracles
but just to explain I mean I I grew up
in parts of the world where religion was
a real problem so I very early on like
Northern Ireland and Israel and so on
and so for me religion is a bit of a
problem and miracles Miracles go along
with that but there are people Charles
eisenstein among them who talk about
miracles as being those moments where
you step from one reality to another
where something that seemed absolutely
impossible suddenly becomes possible and
then inevitable
and I think that form of sort of secular
uh Miracle is is not only possible but
it but it is increasingly happening and
I think the reason I started to work
with business over 40 years ago at the
time when groups like Greenpeace
basically told me if that's what you
want to do that's fine but the only way
to deal with business is to strap them
down with lots of ropes and so on and
just make sure that they can't move and
my response was well I can see why you
might think that but if you're going to
get these people's creative juices
running and so on you're going to have
to give them a bit of freedom and and
and to experiment and so on what were
they afraid of that why should they tie
the businesses all down because at that
time many industries were looking back
now virtually criminal in the sense that
they were doing things that the future
would see as absolutely obscene
um and there were companies I worked
with uh for example there's a company
that no longer exists they're called ICI
and I work with their CEO I work with
their chairman back in the 80s and this
this was during the build up to the
chlorofluorocarbon uh issue or you could
call it a scandal and they were doing
science they were paying for science
that showed there wasn't a problem out
there and then some
uh scientists and and Antarctica but
just put up old-fashioned balloons
and found that there was a huge problem
and just then seeing that that company
just in this they weren't trying to be
criminal but their business models and
their sort of almost ideology locked
them into a world where it was fine to
take from the environment was that
because it was a single bottom line that
it was the prophet that was really
controlling the decisions I think it was
the way that we'd always operated as a
species and particularly as an
international species when people were
forced to live in specific areas places
regions whatever they were also forced
to conserve natural resources and
understand them to a degree when you
were traveling around the world and
bringing back the world's resources you
didn't have to think about that for a
long time and that was just this was the
70s 80s 90s that sort of limits to
growth reality although it was contested
at the time it was just beginning to
come home and that was when you created
a triple bottom line
well that that was 1994. yes
which is is people and planet and profit
yeah and why did you feel the need to
to create that triple bottom line at
that time well in in 1987 we'd set up a
small company called sustainability and
at that time the word wasn't used I mean
universities have done word searches
since and they just haven't found it
um but I I was trying to
sell the notion of sustainability
sustainable development which the
Brunton report had talked about
sustainable development
um to business and I thought well what
does business think about uh and often
it is that the profitability the the
financial bottom line
and it may seem absurd but it it took me
18 months to get from the recognition
that something was needed to those three
words and at the time I just I I
had this when I came up finally with the
triple bottom line phrase I thought I've
heard this before somebody's talked
about this before and I rang all sorts
of people and I got in touch to see who
recognized it no one did
but then many years later I I I
mentioned Future Shock and Alvin Toffler
later on he wrote a book called the
third wave and that was I think
published in 1980 and I read it about
that time
and I was I re-read it and on page I
don't know 236 there was a subheading
which said multiple bottom lines a
multiple and I thought that was it that
was the seed
um and there's nothing really new uh
Under the Sun but language is important
and if you can come up with a concept
that has at least has people asking
questions what the hell is that uh you
know it can't be progress I think today
we are working with multiple definitions
of that theme
businesses work with CSR or ESD or other
other parameters where they look at the
economy the social aspects and so on
um so in some ways it's totally
integrated in how businesses would look
at their bottom line today do you agree
in that
do I have to agree I mean in the sense
that no I'm not sure that's totally true
in the sense that we're currently in a
Tower of Babel situation where everyone
wants to have their language they all
want to have their branding they all
want to have their job you think it's
more branding than actually action often
yes I do and you've seen this mad
Feeding Frenzy around BSG and you know
the triple bottom line did lead to
things like the double bottom line and
all these different things he asked you
know all the rest of it um and I'm at
some level I'm happy that that happened
but I'm unhappy when I see these feeding
frenzies develop where everyone is using
language without necessarily
understanding what what the terms
ought to mean and with the ESG sector in
particular you've recently seen the
European commission starting to strip
the ESG labels of funds sort of holding
and managing hundreds of millions even
trillions of dollars and
I think that's necessary it's sad that
we have to have that overreaction and
then the pullback you reacted to to that
tendons as well about the trouble uh
bottom line you recalled it in in 98
um and you've said it's it was because
everybody had their own interpretation
of it and and you didn't really find
that everybody actually understood what
was the purpose of this is that what's
going is that what's happening also at
the moment with ESG for example I think
so I think the specific reason and you
know I
some people assume that I'm logical some
people assume that I might know what I'm
doing but very often it's intuitive it's
instinctive so with the the recall I'd
work with companies like Ford and Toyota
and Volvo and so on and I'd seen them go
through product recalls where you have a
perfectly good product but it they're a
dysfunction so you pull it back and and
then you fix them and you put it back on
the road or whatever the product's meant
to do
and I thought well it wasn't that there
were lots of different interpretations
so much of the triple bottom line people
planet and profit
it was more that people were using it as
an excuse an alibi to trade off between
I mean to give you a very very basic
example you might have a company that
would say
economic side well we we make a profit
so that's that's that tick well the idea
of the economic dimension of the triple
bottom line was companies and industries
have a much broader economic impact than
is taken to account the normal Financial
bottom line and they might say we're on
the social side well we employ people we
give consumers what they want so that's
you know social take it's a shame about
the environment or it could work other
ways
um but it was just the sense that
as the B Corporation movement spread
around the world there was a very real
risk that as it mainstream the concept
would be diluted out of sight and some
people saw a product recall as just to
end the story you know the idea goes on
the spike that wasn't the idea at all
but I guess a lot of companies will
still find it difficult on how they
merge these
different bottom lines that you know how
because I guess that's that's your idea
you have to think it all together before
it really works in the right way how you
thought of it instead of just ticking
some boxes and said we did some of this
and some of that so so but what are the
good advice if you a company leader and
you actually truly want to work with
this but you find it difficult to really
get these different bottom lines to
merge well I think for a
well-established companies
can be very difficult indeed
particularly if they're driven by
today's financial markets and influenced
by sort of Milton Friedman's you know
the only business the only business of
business is to make a profit style
thinking
the sorts of companies and businesses
that I see that do naturally embrace the
triple bottom line
are quite often family-owned businesses
I mean I'm talking to a company in
Brazil today uh Gerdau big Steel company
family owned and they were talking about
what I understand to be the triple
bottom line you know in a way that it
you know this is I'm always nervous when
people say this is part of our DNA
because
you know it it's it's easy to use
language but it's not often the reality
but I think family-owned businesses are
very often there I think
um The Cooperative movement had a very
strong uh element of this so you could
you can see in the historical economy
examples of people who embraced uh the
triple bottom line the challenge is
that for big companies if you've got to
integrate this and you've got problems
on some parts of the accounting or a
calculus or whatever it it can be quite
difficult to to to to move to a
um a more integrated solution well this
is why I'm terribly excited about the B
corporations many of which are set up
specifically
to pursue a trip or bottom line a
general over six thousand of those
around the the world but you know six
thousand sounds in one sense a big
number in in the context of the tens of
millions of businesses around the world
we'd not even gotten started
but you praised Novo Nordisk for
actually being one of the big companies
who was able to do that what was it you
saw that they did right
well one of the things they did
um was extremely unusual at the time and
at the at the time we just done this
book The Green consumer guide it was a
massive threat to companies like
Northern orders they suddenly found some
of their big customers they then
produced industrial enzymes and so on
which went into detergent products and
so on so they started to find companies
like lever and Procter Gamble and so on
starting to ask very difficult questions
most companies at that time treated us
as you'd expect them to McDonald's sued
us for five months three different parts
of ICI sued us even when I was working
with their chairman three different
businesses were suing us none of them
knowing each other what were they suing
you about
because we said things that they didn't
like about their products and we won
every one of the cases as it happens but
um
it was a period where people were they
still thought that they could bully
their way to an outcome that they were
comfortable with but with nobody Nordisk
that was the normality and what
mazolison did who was then the um the
CEO
he sent two people to a conference I was
speaking at in London and they came up
to me afterwards and they said will you
come to Bowser and see uh CEO
I said I'd I'd love to I mean I I like
visiting companies I like biotechnology
and so on
and we I went there with my young
colleague Julia Hales who had co-written
the book with and she was I think we set
up sustainability together she was I
think 22 at the time so completely
um unexperienced this level but I had
this brilliant brain for asking
difficult questions in a in a friendly
way so anyway we went to see much and he
said you can go anywhere in this company
you want you can talk to anyone you want
to
you can ask them anything you like come
back and tell me what you found
and we did that we we went back to
London then we came again
I think we talked about 30 people there
and at the end of it we came back and
said there are three things we think you
should do
and they did them all and we thought
they were going to be a real real
stretch and then after that we probably
worked with the company for about 20
years off and on
um three things can you tell us the
three things that they had to do well
one of them was invite the outside world
in because at that time companies would
read in the paper about what
campaigning groups were saying um and
we'd say well why didn't you invite them
in and talk to them because at that
stage they wouldn't they wouldn't even
think of doing that
so we suggested a process where and it
turned out to be an annual event
where we would invite 12 or 14.
troublemakers I mean people who didn't
like biotechnology didn't like genetic
engineering and so on and and we put
them in front
um
of Senior Management at at the company
they have to find out the good arguments
then that's good well what one of the
things that the companies then and now
it's it's become more typical to do that
stakeholder engagement and all the rest
of it then it was just it was not done
but one of the things that the company
people found most interesting was to
listen to the stakeholders talking among
themselves about trading off between
their own issues and their own
perspectives of different parts of this
what from a business point of view
looked like a coherent agenda was you
know very much
multifaceted so that that's how that
started but then something absolutely
terrible happened I mean if you wanted
to script what could go wrong in the
worst possible way
um it happened the second year we did
this strange thing of getting not the
company Northern orders to invite the
stakeholders in we got the people who
came the first year none of whom came
back to ask the people for the second
year oh uh and so it was you know
peer-to-peer
first evening I remember being in the
hotel in Copenhagen and they were
watching everyone was watching this
television news program number one story
was an accidental release of genetically
modified organisms from a Nova nordist
plant in the heart of Copenhagen you
could not have scripted something that
would have been more
just appalling and and for a moment it
looked as though the whole thing would
pull over people were going to go home
and so on and somebody said
let's go in and listen to what they have
to say
and the next morning there were 70
people from Nova Nordic
and and somebody stood up on the I won't
say who he was but he was an engineer
and he was a lawyer and it's a terrible
combination sometimes
um and he got up on the stage and he
said something I did I'm dramatizing but
don't worry your pretty little heads
this sort of thing happens all the time
oh okay
there was this moment
and I had to decide in a sort of an
instant what to do
and his CEO was in front of him board
members are in front of him
I walked onto the stage and I steered
him off the stage without saying
anything and I just said to a younger
woman in the um front row Lisa can go
very very young on the margins of the
company then Lisa come up and take over
and she did
and she did it brilliantly well
um but it's one of it I often say I'm
not political
but there are politics that go with
stakeholder engagement and if I hadn't
done that
I I don't know what the outcome would
have been but it wouldn't have been good
that person ever forgave me but you know
it was a price well worth paying yeah
but to listen to your critics that's
actually uh a very good takeaway yeah on
how you should push forward your company
is there is there other you know
you you don't have to take us through
all three you can do that but you know
is there is there the takeaways that you
often say to companies okay you have
this well-established company it's it's
difficult for you to turn the whole
business around in your bottom lines so
how do you how do you see the potential
or how do you rephrase how you
how you
um
you know it also explained the purpose
of this company both to your
employers and customers well the third
thing that we suggested to match that
they do and it's something that was not
only two companies in the world had done
it at the time was produce an annual
environmental later sustainability
report companies just didn't they didn't
want to share that information and and
um
and we also said and when you do it have
the data verified which again you know
was quite a process but we did it for
several reasons one is we felt the
information was needed in The Wider
world but we thought that the very
process of going through that reporting
exercise would force a company like
novanortis to think about some of the
stuff even more deeply than they perhaps
had done to that date because it was
going public and at that stage it's not
true now in the same way but the board
or the CEO had to sign off on the report
because it you know was this was a big
deal so as I say they they took on board
these different uh things and then they
they launched the first one of the very
first triple bottom line uh reports and
things just went from there
do you see a lot of green washing today
it's always there and and
um I've always felt that greenwashing is
not necessarily a bad thing in the sense
that people again were hurt animal whip
you know everything
is exciting and suddenly we want to be
part of it as well and if everyone is
talking green then we want to talk green
too and I always say that if people
accompany particularly but makes their a
brand makes a mistake
um an honest mistake and and then
reverses it in short order that's fine
that you know that we all learn in that
slightly messy way but if it if it
repeats
then you hit them very hard
um so now we're seeing uh impact washing
ESG washing all of these different games
uh being played and there are a lot of
public relations agencies you know
playing into that space too I think it's
deadly because it undermines confidence
of the ordinary citizen in what's being
said so again I think we have to act
quite quickly to stop that wherever we
can yeah The credibility to disappears
if it's um if it's out there in the open
but do companies do a lot of
greenwashing because the consumers
actually want a more green company
economical aware company and goods you
you wrote a bestseller about the green
consumer and
do you see a strong Trend in that as
well today that the consumer can
actually turn around companies and how
they look at these different aspects of
the bottom line
I think to start with a lot of green
washing was done in the hope that this
new breed of green consumers would sort
of go away some you know quite quickly
and and consumer action and and concern
can often only be sustained for a few
years
but but it didn't totally go away
um and so the green washing was not
totally effective but it wasn't helpful
and another thing wasn't helpful which
is that people took actions they avoided
certain products or whatever it was or
they picked Greener Brands but no one
then told them what had happened as a
result of what they'd done supermarkets
had no interest in feeding back to them
governments weren't they did equal
labeling but they really wanted didn't
want to do that at any great scale
and now what you've got is just that
it's it's the washing is being done with
the greatest sophistication
and therefore it's sometimes harder to
challenge
um but again I I do think it's really
important that we do pick out the the
worst cases uh and I think people like
the European commission are trying to uh
do that and I I think that's healthy
but again I just think it's so other
customers or other companies could get
it out in the open do you think that we
could rely on customers to push a green
agenda still no
by which I mean most of us have busy
lives and you know even with silence
there everybody was afraid okay we
actually still have empowerment in our
ways of going to the supermarket or what
else but you don't think that there's
that huge and impact or I think I think
consumer action
and shareholder action and these sorts
of things done well
can have an immense impact as long as
there are enough people doing it and as
long as they sustain the pressure
because it's like being a member of the
European Parliament or Member of
Parliament in the country if you're if
you if you still get letters or emails a
few emails or a few letters are a signal
that there's a broader area of concern
so green consumers or ethical consumers
or whatever they're called
um concerned consumers or conscious
consumers or whatever and that's part of
the problem because you know you get
these multiple iterations but they they
can have the big bit like shock troops
they can they can have they can shop
businesses into acting because if if it
starts to affect a business brand and
it's it's sort of Market reputation
that that can be quite uh immobilizing
uh influence the reason why I say no is
because what very often happens
and it certainly happened with the green
consumer guide where in very short order
in some cases within a few months
the impact of the book which was which
was surfing a wave of activism
uh was so great that that many of the
things we talked about in the book had
changed people had taken particular
problem chemicals out of their processes
or products or whatever so it can work
but again people
you know I'm the same I I do not want to
think every time I buy something you
know where does this come from take my
cell phone scan the QR code go down and
look at all the you know the problems
the political system before that that
has to have acted as well we actually
you want Gatekeepers you want people who
will do that work for you who you trust
so if you buy in supermarkets you want
the supermarkets to do that so the
target often has to then be the
supermarket so sort of try and get them
to act but yeah I think it's clear that
we talk about this that it's a whole
other field uh in doing business in that
it was maybe 20 or 30 years ago and both
on how the consumers the politicians the
technology Works
um and of course we have both some
students we have some Business Leaders
in here what could you tell us about
what is it what are the best criterias
for being a great leader in this area
now and in the future to be born that
way I think I mean initially when you
have an area like this the people who
are the pioneers people like Anita
erotic at The Body Shop you know Ben and
Jerry uh Evon shoe and I at Patagonia
this is who they are this is what they
want to be in life
but over time can you teach yourself I
think that's the problem with the
question that some people ask them well
I I think you can and I think if you
once switch on and I I've come across
quite a number of companies of CEOs and
Senior leaders in business who suddenly
have a moment where something changes
and the most dramatic case probably was
Ray Anderson at interface who would
often say he read Paul Hawkins book The
Ecology of Commerce in which Paul talks
about in the future CEOs today will be
seen as criminals because you know
they're destroying the environment the
rest and Ray decided to describe that as
a spear in the chest it was a moment way
he decided he had to
think differently and act differently
and and and began to most people don't
have that moment where you know
everything changes
for them and one of the things I think
is happening now but very late in the
day is I've taught at business schools
for something like 30 years
and when I first started doing it it was
only because the students themselves
wanted it or one strange faculty member
and was trying to do even in schools
like in Seattle IMD it was it was always
one mutant uh faculty member who who saw
something here that was worth doing now
you have for example the financial times
doing its ranking of Business Schools
sustainability is coming up the the the
the the
um the notion that this is now something
absolutely core to what Business Leaders
should be learning is I think it's it's
late but it's exciting that it's
happening and then it's not so dependent
on somebody being born that way or
having a spear in the chest because it's
what a natural part of CEOs do but
should the Business Schools change the
way they teach students yes
I mean in a sense that I mean there's
such a spectrum of different Business
Schools and we're currently working with
a number one of them is shizen can
University in Tokyo so they're set up to
be a business school for the 22nd
century which is a sort of level of
ambition I quite uh like and we're
working with people like ASC ISC and
Spain government business school and so
on and trying to pull together a a
course which is like the MBA course for
the future
but at the moment it's still very often
having to happen on the outsides of the
Business Schools or in networks of them
to give themselves you know strength in
numbers
um I think in every area of our
societies and economies
and this is not going to be welcome to
some older people in the audience
um people can be retrained people can
decide to think differently and behave
differently but what should the schools
do should they throw about wave Friedman
or what I think they should remove
tenure in the sense that no
faculty members strain every sinew to
get tenure and once they get it they can
swan around forever
that's a problem because that older body
of
um
professors in economics and so on
there's some great ones but most of them
suffer from what David Suzuki describes
as a brain disease economics as it was
is a brain disease and we've got to get
rid of these people and if they can
retrain if they're willing well
wonderful but if then if they can't
we've sort of got to move up the younger
folk really much what would you replace
them with
AI okay no I mean it's got to be a
combination of of significantly younger
people people with practical experience
of dealing I mean I find myself in this
really ridiculous position now of being
a visiting professor at three different
universities and I love it because I
don't have to play The Faculty politics
I can parachute in I did one last week
at Imperial College I've done that for
25 years and then I can parachute out
the same day and then some of the
students come on and do projects with us
or join the team order
so I think
younger people have to be brought in I
think people with practical experience
of dealing with these sorts of problems
in or challenges or opportunities in
business and financial markets and in
government
and also activist groups I think I I
think ngos are an extraordinary
reservoir of
the Greenpeace member in your board
um
it's happened and there have been
Greenpeace people who started out uh you
know in in in working and campaigning
and went into business or even when
politics or whatever I think that's
totally healthy uh as long as they
remember who they are right the process
but I slightly jokingly said Ai and we
talked a little earlier on about Ai and
I don't think it's going to save us
remotely but I don't think we can do
what we now need to do including
business Education Without a really
rapid Evolution and AI do you see AI as
a green or a Black Swan
well if if Nasim Nicholas Talib was here
he would say black swans include
Solutions they're not I'm just simply
sort of squeezed out this green bit
um I think there'll be both and I think
that
um
they will cause I mean AI systems are
already causing problems because you
know they they won't recognize black
faces or whatever it is because all the
people doing the coding are are white
young man or whatever I mean you know
the stories
um and that's very small beer I
mentioned the
um ozone layer problem there was a
satellite that flew over Antarctica
every week a day after day or week after
week and number seven and it looked down
and it was blind to what was happening
why was it blind because the coding and
the satellite or actually on the
computers that process the data that
were streaming back the coding was done
in such a way that nothing like that was
possible so if the data came in showing
there was a problem dump it because that
couldn't be reality and I think with the
AI we'll very often do the same thing so
build in our blind spots we'll build in
our assumptions and prejudices and and
that's why I think ai's got open up
and be challenged and and so bringing
you know ngos and others onto the boards
of Deep Mind or some of the people who
are doing this work now I think it's got
to be done sooner rather than later and
isn't it interesting that Microsoft I
think disbanded their ethics uh Team not
idiotic move
all right but before we are getting
replaced by AI I just want to touch a
little bit more about the skills the
management skills the leadership skills
what was what is required in in the
future I read that you said somewhere
that we have a narrow window of showing
our responsibility to the world before
we are run over by history
I've recently been reading a book by
Andreas maruma some people will know him
it's a book called how to blow up
Pipelines
part of that narrow window is I think
we're going to see new forms of activism
coming up where people decide enough
already we've tried lobbying we've tried
campaigns the fossil fuels industry is
just digging in deeper it's investing in
you know fossil fuel resources that will
guarantee that we go to three to four to
five degrees
blow the buggers up I mean just go out
and blow up their pipelines I don't
support that but I think you're starting
to see people wondering
if we can't get it then through
democracy
how can we get at them and I I think
that when I think about a narrow window
of opportunity I'm not just thinking
about the science I'm thinking about
politically we have young people around
the world now who feel betrayed
equal anxiety has increasingly talked
about when I first heard that um six or
seven years ago I just I thought they're
making it up but it is uh not only a
reality nature magazine you probably
know but did a survey uh 18 months or so
ago and it was International 10 000
young people where in the world are
people feeling the greatest Eco anxiety
Philippines
Indonesia Brazil very close to the
change and you know very close to the
problems and and when you come to Europe
which European member state is uh
showing greatest evidence Portugal
because more or less on the survey it
was done the fires were blazing and so
on so I I think we've got a very narrow
window in which to persuade younger
people that democracy and capitalism and
and markets and business and so on have
the will to solve this and and have a
good chance of solving it because
otherwise I think things will start to
unravel and unravel quite quickly
so far is that you see the awesome
optimistic perspective in how business
develops and there are new ideas new
technologies and so on
um but when I hear you talk about the
political system like that yes it seems
like you think that part at least of the
political system is broken
does anyone Wonder in the audience
disagree I mean I mean
what I'm thinking is yeah yeah we as
I've been a
reporter for years as well I've I've
followed the UN Trail and Well Done
visited cops all around the world
that was a lot of waiting
um and what frustrated me was that there
was so little done because everybody had
to agree and it was very clear to me
that the political system could not
really make the progress
um and the change that was needed it was
too slow so what what have happened is
that it is the consumers it is the
business and that is actually driving
the change what happens then is that you
will actually have the Business Leaders
the people with the money the people
with the ideas that is driving this
change and maybe not the political
system maybe not that the the people who
are elected
through a democracy
is is that a problem well it's a huge
problem I mean
there's so many different aspects of
this but I I've only met Bill Gates once
he's a strange fellow but he's obviously
a very brilliant man and I look at his
almost super philanthropy into areas
like controlling malaria developing new
uh generations of nuclear reactor and so
on and I think it's it's great that he's
doing some of that work and some of
these other extraordinarily wealthy
uh multi-millionaires and
multi-billionaires and the rest of it
but
they're not democratically elected and I
think it would be better to tax them
and efficiently and effectively spend
the tax money rather than allow these
super concentrations of wealth but it's
not only a matter of money is it it's
also a matter of being able to make a
decision and actually get something done
I think that's a huge problem about the
political system that even though you
have the money even though you have the
ideas you cannot have the majority of
votes to actually get something done
that you can get in the business look I
can talk about what business can do
constructively and positively and
creatively and I'm happy to do that but
if you look at what the billionaires are
starting to do they're buying up bunkers
in New Zealand and then and Patagonia
and so on they can see the systemic
consequences of what they've been they
want their safe houses out somewhere
they want a place to sort of retreat and
but the question is you know who's going
to guard them uh when they're in those
sort of bunkers and the rest of it and
it that again is an example of of people
but what you're saying is that you don't
really trust them to do this do you
trust them
if like if they actually live by the
triple bottom line but I guess that's
what we're questioning right we're
questioning that if the profit is
actually still what drives the business
I don't think any billionaire in the
world has become a billionaire by doing
what I would properly understand to be
triple bottom line Market building
organizational development all the rest
of it I in fact they've generally got
there by doing something rather
different I mean Microsoft I mentioned
look at look at their behavior with
something like that Netscape as soon as
a competitor comes up you squash it dead
um and and it's a very very brutal
game that these people play and over
time whatever they start out as being
They do change and you know I it's not
that I dislike them
um and you know I I've been sort of
privileged enough to sort of meet quite
a few of them and work with quite a few
of them and
I think the younger generation of
Business Leaders understand this now in
a visceral way
and one of the things I've noticed very
very strikingly and it happened in the
1990s particularly in the United States
it's now happening again in Europe where
directors of major companies will say my
children are beating me up at The
Breakfast Table about this I'm going to
have to do that something about this I
know it
um so you know there's that emotional
charge yeah but what should we do to get
them to act responsible
what what is the parameter is it
security
well security I think is is becoming an
increasingly important factor and if you
think about the pandemic got 90 cop 19
covered 19. if I forgotten it already
um but but covid-19 sort of sort of came
out of the blue uh it wasn't a Black
Swan even Talib said that he said we saw
it coming we should have prepared we
didn't
you know it's a standard pattern
um but that was a shock and then came
the Ukraine conflict and some some of
this sort of massive dislocation of
energy markets and so on so after a
couple of decades where we lived in
Freedom and La La Land I mean yeah yeah
and I think what we're now hearing is
you you listen to Business Leaders who
listen to politicians and they're
talking about security by which they're
also meaning water security and you look
at what's happening in Spain
at the moment uh you know these few
weeks they're talking about resilience
and you hear that all the time how do
you build resilience into individuals
into teams into organizations into
economies and societies and so on
and that's not something we've actually
grown up particularly knowing how to do
we're going to have to come up that
learning curve very rapidly in the best
of leaders whatever sector they're in
will work out how to do that and learn
from each other very very rapidly and
the Business Schools are lagging the
curve on a lot of that stuff at the
moment and of course it's you know it's
it's affecting the green agenda uh but
suddenly it's it's a totally different
area to work in we've had also we had a
what 30 years of freedom and
globalization we were getting used to
that the goods could just move around
the world freely and then suddenly we
had the pandemic and we were missing
that chip from China and then suddenly
we had the war and we couldn't get our
energy and it occurred to us that even
you know maybe we couldn't just
you couldn't just get this globalization
uh working without there was there was
there's going to be something that
that you we were stopped in doing that
in some way with the pandemic and now
the war and how does that shift the
whole Marketplace in which we are going
to make a green agenda and the climate
change well their shifts seismic shifts
starting to have no markets around
energy and so on and some of that is
positive in the sense that
investment and and renewable energy and
Battery Technology and smart grids and
so on and thinking about how do you link
electric vehicles together as a
distributed battery and all the rest of
it that stuff is being taken seriously
in a way that uh very often it wasn't in
the past
but the risk is that when people start
to think about security they think about
the military and they think about I in
fact I did a session with Britain's
Armed Forces early last year and it was
sort of generals and it was Admirals and
what they're thinking about now is
climate change but they're thinking
about climate change because it's a real
headache when you start to think about
migration and you know the numbers were
panicking about at the moment a tiny
compared to what is coming so
to your question earlier on about what
Business Leaders can do practically to
deal with this and one of the things
um and covet has got us into the habit
of not going out very much I mean it's
lovely to be in an audience and you know
with people
um but one of the things I try and tell
to people and not just CEOs I mean chief
financial officers other people at that
c-suite level board level whatever
go and see some of the things that are
already happening in this world where
people are developing practical
Solutions
and there was a case some years ago now
but a a
group called Leader's Quest take groups
of uh Business Leaders to strange places
and there was a German company car
company automotive company that asked to
be taken in Silicon Valley to see an
electric vehicle company
and they went
and the chairman of the German
automotive company was
extremely powerful man cashmere code I
mean just you know just used to being
treated like the German foreign minister
and all the rest of it okay
he visited the company and they said we
don't understand why you're there here
they said in 10 years would have driven
you off the road
you won't exist
he then the the chairman then went to uh
um and what happened well he went to the
restroom and he was overheard to say to
somebody else
forgive the language but I've been
briefed on this I've read about it I've
seen television programs this is the
first time viscerally
I'm experiencing the the nature of the
market challenge that is coming up we've
got to scramble to catch up now we've
seen Munich we've seen Detroit all these
centers of the conventional Exquisite
internal combustion engine engineering
starting to feel that this is sort of
turning and in very short order into a
very different sort of um market so I
think get out more go and see some of
the people who are working on some of
this new including ai go and talk to
some other people who are working on AI
when I've done that I find it
shocking in a way I mean I really like
them I find fascinating I find it
fascinating what they're doing but
they're like a different species their
brains work five or six times faster
than mine mine does uh and and they're
they're very seized with developing
Solutions in in this sustainability
space tackling climate change is their
future as well
but dealing with them is dealing is very
different from dealing with the
traditional business people
but just as we just talk a bit about
more about the changes that happens in
the world you talk about go out and see
how they work in different places other
parts of the world and so on do you
think that the changes we see at the
moment which is not just a regional
conflict in Ukraine but it's actually
Shifting the whole world order yeah and
the Great South is really you know
really chipping in in in in empowering
um do you see do you see a shift in how
how the green agenda will work in this
world New World Order where you also
have China as a huge player yeah
well I've worked in China and very few
countries frighten me as much as China
in the sense that I really it's a
fascinating country I love being there
but the Neville of nationalism is off
the scale greater than even Japan where
again I've worked a fair amount over
there yes so I when I look at Ukraine I
see the Spanish Civil War I think
there's a much bigger conflict
potentially coming Henry Kissinger has
gone public with his advice on how we
can avoid a third world war but there is
a pattern to these things and in the
same way about you mentioned the
geopolitical order
it's absolutely inevitable that that
will change that the sort of post-second
World War uh order that we've grown up
with with the World Bank and the UN and
so on that's now being challenged and
and and and over time it's not a tall
guarantee that that will continue and I
I see this as almost like a u-bend
moment where where an old order starts
to come apart at an accelerating rate
and that is inevitable firstly but it's
necessarily it's necessary because until
the old order starts to wobble you can't
get the new ones coming through uh fast
enough and powerfully enough so it oddly
I find that makes me optimistic what I
just said uh although you know I don't
we've been very lucky not having a
really major war for a very long time
but that in itself is dangerous but can
it change you know can it drive Humanity
forward that we have this change in the
world Oro and I'm asking The Optimist
yes
thank God
but but you know right
one of the things that struck me working
with China is how they're very acutely
aware of certain environmental issues so
if you go to the Eastern Seaboard cities
air quality major problems schools being
shut down because you know the Olympics
I was there during the Olympic period
and you could only see this oxy
acetylene burners around the bird's nest
building through the smog just these
tiny distant bright Sparks so there are
certain issues that they're really
concerned about and now they're in
danger of really losing face because
they're the biggest greenhouse gas
emitter in the world
I think what they're doing around
renewable energy around electric
vehicles is both exciting in a climate
frame because they're coming up with
Solutions very fast and terrifying in
terms of The Wider global economy
because their capacity to uh you know
just jump uh
that's the word LeapFrog in these
Technologies
um
why is it so why is it so terrifying
well if you believe that we can catch up
and that that you know a competitive
threat like that really Sparks in the
same way the inflation reduction act in
the United States is now sparking
European sort of counter reactions then
that's not so terrifying
but I I
like individual Chinese but the idea of
a world dominated by China
I don't find that a terribly attractive
proposition not that I find the US uh
you know infinitely amusing or or
um uh you know
reassuring but at least they have this
sense of a somewhat Democratic World
Order
probably happen is that we won't have a
bipolar world order as we're used to
we'll probably have a multi-polar for a
while and then I think it will
consolidate and converge again on
something
two or three core
concentrations of power but your
question I think the green agenda has
the potential to become an immensely
influential Force even in that very
disturbed environment actually in some
ways particularly in that
because it talks of and I mean it's
funny because when I first became an
environmentalist for 20 years my parents
didn't understand what had happened to
me and and even the people who educated
were they worried or
they thought I should have become a
merchant Banker or gone into the air
force with something grown up I think
they were worried they thought that you
know how could you possibly make a
living out of um all of that but there
was a tendency then in business to say
anyone who is Green it's the watermelon
you know they're cut really Communists
they've been quite well camouflaged yeah
so um but also people would say the
green stuff it's basically a religion
people are responding into this in the
same way that the wood occult
I've always felt around the
sustainability agenda there is something
very much like the architecture of a
religion and there's something about the
human brain which likes religious
structures I mean we we have different
ones and they compete but even communism
was a religion and we keep defaulting to
that sort of form of World Order and
it's partly about something bigger than
us of the Earth
things that go on it's after lives but
it's afterlies of other human beings
other species it does a code of behavior
that comes with it there are a sense of
there's a sense of order that could come
with it and so
I I think you may find I once I was once
in China and talking to their
environment Minister and he he kidnapped
me and a colleague and literally
kidnapped me and took me off into a
little Resort and we just squeezed me
poor man for everything that I could say
and one of the things we talked about
was the prospect of
the the
ecological crisis sparing a spiritual
and religious
um uh response and he was absolutely
fascinated by that because in China
they've seen these moments where things
just go berserk and and these vast
social movements start so I think the
green agenda could be very powerful in
that but there's one condition
and that is the green politicians and
people who Embrace that agenda change
agenda whether it's in business or the
financial markets or whatever
they get out there and talk to the
people who are creating the new economy
now
and when I've gone to see people working
on AI or synthetic biology or whatever
and I asked them who who else are you
talking about to from the sustainability
world
that reply we're not
because we're looking backwards we're
looking at fossil fuels and chemicals
and automotive and construction and
Aerospace we're not looking at what's
the the basically the operating code of
the new and and there may well be people
in the room who are doing that I'm
desperate to hear from them okay
do you actually think that this
uncertainty of times can maybe drive
forward that new thinking that we talked
about in the beginning where the social
or the cultural aspect will be essential
for the driver of the next change
I think culture without culture change
this isn't going to happen in the time
that we need and
cost efficiently and all the other stuff
that we need to happen culture changes
though as you know are very peculiar you
can talk about them and Mao tried to do
it and he ended up killing 70 million
Chinese people but
um well I mean
we now do the numbers and we see that
was the reality at the time you know I I
came from a generation where many of
them waved the Little Red Book
um and and believed in all of that
these sort of social excursions these
moments where people become incredibly
excited or incredibly frightened by
something can trigger perverse movements
and I think one of the reasons I'd like
to see the sustainability agenda the
green movements and so on being more
powerful and more effective is it's
almost like a vaccination against some
of that sort of stuff it's it's a it's a
sense of belief that this can be this
corner can be turned and I still and
maybe I'm delusional but I genuinely
believe that we we're very close into
sorting it out or we don't
let's finish off by talking a little bit
about the future ah bat
um because you wrote about a book about
sworns and now I know you're writing a
book about sharks
yes what is what is that about what
should we expect
well this is a book that um
sort of jumped up on me in a way it was
something that I felt I had to write and
it's sort of i as I travel around the
world I'm often asked why are you doing
this what started you off you know it's
almost the origin story you you're such
a mutant something strange must have
happened so I thought well I'll tell
elements of the life story and I've been
50 years professionally involved in this
field now and I when I started it was
the environmental wave then there was a
Green Wave and there was a system
sustainability wave and then what I call
the Greta wave where sort of younger
people became much more
um
energized and now it's it's it's
fragmenting a bit it's sort of impact
and a lot of other things coming through
at the same time ESG and so on and so I
I was starting to think what is the
characteristic
of the work that I've done over decades
and a lot of it has been getting in very
close to people who are very powerful
very influential used to having their
own way
in Europe we talk about tickling trout
when you get into the river and you sort
of tickle them underneath in America in
places like Florida they talk about
tickling catfish problem with tickling
cam fluids is the catfish live in hulls
quite often and there are things called
moccasin snakes and there's a very
deadly uh game but I I thought well a
lot of what I've done is like tickling
pickling tickling pickling uh powerful
people uh it's getting close enough in
to
distract them to make them think in a
different way
and there was one sort of really for me
one of the one of the defining moments
in in my professional life was 2005
Hurricane Katrina hit
um New Orleans
um Walmart very powerful uh
supermarket chain decided that they
would put pressure on this their supply
chain to clean up and and deal with
Energy Efficiency within four or five
months I had invitations to do sessions
with the board of DuPont big Chemical
Company and 3M and the 3M exercises in
Minnesota so I traveled all that way I
did the board meeting and right at the
end of the board meeting a woman came up
to me and she was one of the board
directors
and she had originally been trained as a
psychologist
and she said
why do you use humor
in a situation like this and I I can't
tell jokes I can't remember them so it's
all situational it's all in the moment
you're playing off something that
somebody is saying and she said
I think it works
and I she thought it worked for two
reasons the first was I wasn't being a
missionary I was I was signaling that I
could play with my own agenda
but then the shock was I was playing
with them in a situation in an
environment where people didn't play
with them and so she said The Reptilian
part of their brain will be thinking if
he's able to do that the size of his
army must be enormous and and to some
degree I think it's true that no I've
you you can use a business case you can
use logic but sometimes you just have to
compete at people in a in a slightly
different angle brain in from a
different angle yeah wow
uh just as a final question yes this is
the deadly one so this is no no I'm nice
so you you can be um you can be calm um
I just wanted to ask you if you should
recommend the audience to read something
I know you have 20 books they can start
out there
but I heard somewhere that if you should
recommend books you often recommend
sci-fi I do why is that
I think science fiction is
really intelligent people trying to
think around corners trying to think
what if
so there's a book called The Water knife
which is about what happens in the
United States when what's happened to
the Colorado River which it doesn't
reach the sea when I went down it 30
years ago even then it didn't reach the
sea Mississippi is headed in the same
direction what happens when the U.S is
starved of water one thing that happens
is you get water wars suddenly Texans
are treated like Mexicans are today you
you read a scenario like that it's a
fictional story you think oh hadn't
thought of it that way but but it's a
fully realized version of a potential
future Kim Stanley Robinson is somebody
the ministry
of the future but I can never remember
it's all before but brilliant book a bit
like a novelized MBA dissertation in
some ways but but part way through the
book which is about the species solving
the climate problem
there's a very short section
where he talks about Black Ops
where assassins start to go out and kill
fossil fuel
company CEOs and then very quickly
slides away from that
but
again I think one of the things that
we're being seduced into believing at
the moment on the Andreas Mountain book
how to block a pipeline I I would be one
of the things I would recommend very
short very readable pretty bracing if
you think that you can work with
business and change them but he's
basically a thing we've been lulled into
the belief that non-violence will
deliver the results that we want and
we're told that the slavery was ended
because people were non-violent
actually the slave rebellions in the
Caribbean is what terrified slave owners
suffragettes only when the women walk
down Downing Street and started throwing
bricks through Windows did people pay
attention Martin Luther King if there
hadn't been Malcolm X from the Black
Panthers JFK would not have signed off
on that legislation so
I think we need to read round the edges
of our subject if there was one final
book which I wish people could absorb
but I don't recommend reading it was a
book that I read when I was 14 in 1963
the structure of scientific revolutions
by Thomas Kuhn it's the first time
anyone talked about Paradigm shifts
and in that book and I I often go back
and reread it because I can't believe
what I remember having read there and
and his notion is that a paradigm shift
a proper one and we're going through one
The Love Lock science is very much part
of it the anthropocene moment is part of
it
it takes 70 to 80 years to come through
because you need to
the people infected with the old
Paradigm to die or at least retire the
people they taught to retire or die but
then he said something which which is
what I keep going back to and and trying
to remember whether it could possibly be
true I won't go through the full story
but just
that when paradigms do shift the people
trapped in the L Paradigm become almost
nauseated by this New Logic this new
reality that's coming up and I think
we're very close into that starting to
happen and what we've now got to do is
very actively manage older people
include I'm a bit I'm a baby boomer
the older people are going to be one of
our biggest headaches because they
become more conservative they've become
and in their pension policies they want
to go into safe uh businesses and
Investments they're not going to invest
in you know the the startups they're
going to really change the world we're
going to have to seduce those people
into supporting younger people and not
just their family members but putting
their wealth and their influence and
their voting behavior behind disruptive
change that's going to be an interesting
challenge for the next 10 to 15 years
sure
well I think that if we should get some
inspiration to how to see green Swans in
the air we will all read some more
science fiction that's a lovely
recommendation
John elkinson thank you so much for all
your insights it was a pleasure talking
to you thank you so much for the
audience for listening thank you thank
you all very much thank you
thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]